okay you're now live
good afternoon i would like to welcome
you all to this virtual meeting of the
auditing governance
on tuesday the 28th of july i will just
go through some basic rules for the
meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones except mine the chairs
please leave all microphones muted
unless you are asked to speak
by me to indicate
to me that you would like to speak or
propose or second emotion
please press the raise the hand symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in order
that they
are pressed and i will deal with them in
the order
giving the appropriate officer or
counselor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary
i will also return to the counselor to
check that they are happy with the
response
to ensure accuracy and clarity during
the virtual meetings
all notes will be all votes will be cast
via the verbal recorded vote and names
will be read out in alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency
with the democratic process this meeting
is being
live streamed on the council's youtube
channel
we are in unprecedented times and i ask
you all to be patient during this
meeting
and to understand the processes and
advice given
may take longer than usual
now on to our main agenda item one
register of attendance and committee
clerk to read out names
and for the members to confirm their
attendance
thank you chair okay councillor craigee
yeah here councillor hackett
here councillor heppel
not here yet he is going to be late um
councillor hodson
present councillor jones
yeah and councillor laws
thank you thank you very much kirsty
do we have any apologies for absences
thank you chair yes apologies for
absence received from
councillor rossi however council of laws
is substituting for him and also
um rob hutchins from the devon audit
partnership
um isn't isn't here but dominic measures
has taken his place
thank you okay thank you kirsty and
thank you very much
council laws thank you nick for turning
up and for dominic
to come along as well in place of rob
thank you item two confirmation of the
minutes
uh we'll confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st of january 2020
pages four to nine um if we would like
to just
check through from pages four
page five
page six
page seven
page eight and finally
page nine i'm happy to propose from the
chair
that is the correct record of the
meeting do i have a seconder please
counselor hodgson you've indicated you'd
like to speak
i'm seconding your proposal
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much councillor hodson
right can we take a recorded vote please
kirsty
thank you chair yes councillor craigie
um for councillor hackett
for councillor hudson
or councillor jones
i'll have to abstain as i wasn't at that
meeting i've really just joined
committee
okay thank you and councillor laws
abstain for
the same reason okay um as councillor
heckler arrived yet
hey no sorry no kissing no okay
so that's three four and two abstentions
thank you kirsty thank you
right we'll now move on to
item three which is the action list
which appears on
page ten
chris would you like to take us through
the action list
as it stands just talk us through it
yes um the first item was about um
inviting mark gaylor from devon county
council to talk about the um
pension that's going to happen at the
september meeting
um 22nd september he's going to come
along
next one was an email to be sent about
safeguarding
um which i think happened in back in
september
the third one is that is now a gender
item 12 today that'll be on today's on
today's agenda
the fourth one the um section 106 one is
it was distributed in the members
bulletin
and the fifth one is with um
i was a chief executive i think i don't
know if steve's there you can comment on
the fifth one
yes steve would you like to comment
sorry i'm remember to turn my mood off
um
so chair i i'll need to find out what's
happened with that media i think that
meeting
took place um i'm not clear
exactly what's happened with the the
roles with the the chief executive so
i'll have to
follow that up to if that's okay that's
fine
thank you very much indeed steve thank
you
right item number four declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
discussed
item number five agreement of agenda
items
part one and two we will be going to
part one and two so i would like to take
a recorded vote
at this time please i'm happy to propose
from the chair could i have a seconder
please
council hobson is that seconding the
motion thank you
kirsty if you'd like to do a roll
thank you chair councillor craigie for
councillor hackett for councillor hudson
or councillor james
four councillor laws or
thank you that's unanimous thank you
item six urgent matters of information
to be brought forward
with permission of the chair i do not
have any items to bring forward today
item 7 grant thornton update
report march 2020
and this is to receive the report from
andrew davis of grant thornton
our external auditors so that starts on
page 11
over to andrew
thank you cheer um so
this is um if you remember back to
to march 2020 the ordinance audit and
governance committee was
cancelled so the this this update report
along with the audit plan that
follows it was circulated back in march
for information and to ask questions
remotely we did have a few questions to
which
i responded to however discussing with
with david with david hayes we thought
that it was a good idea to put these
back onto the agenda
just because it gives people the
opportunity
to ask questions on on them in
in real time so i wasn't planning to go
through these because they're reports
that
have already been circulated and it was
more that if anyone had got any
questions on that they wanted to discuss
in more detail
this was a good opportunity to to do it
um before in terms just in terms of an
update though before
i open it up to any questions on those
and subsequent to
the march meeting we have issued a plan
addendum to management
and this was in response to uh kovid 19
the the global pandemic
that we're all acutely aware of and what
what that effectively set out
was you know the potential impact of
that in terms of
of in terms of like remote working in
terms of
increased uncertainty around valuations
um all those things that have been
potentially impacted logistically
on being able to a for the finance team
to be able to get the
financial statements prepared but also
in terms of delivery of the audit
so that is kind of where we are i mean
up
i think there's a later agenda item
where i i'm going to give an update on
the actual audit progress
at present so i'll if that's okay chair
i'll pause there if there's any
questions
on that that's fine thank you
does anybody wish to raise any questions
on that item
no right thank you very much andrew we
will note
that item and we now move on to item
eight
where we will review the external audit
plan
and this is to receive the reports from
andrew davis again of grant thornton
our external auditors and this
corresponds with pages
29 to 46 of our agenda
yeah thanks chair so i i sort of
summarized this in the last one as well
in that
this was also on the march this was on
the march agenda
so people have already seen a copy of
the external
audit plan this is our plan that is uh
communicates the significant risks on
the audit um
which which are set out within that it
communicates
fees and sort of our independence
again i wasn't going to go into this
again and go through it on a page by
page basis
because it's already been taken to
committee
yes okay right i'll just ask if anybody
wishes to speak
any questions points to raise
okay that's fine it has been to the
march agenda as you say andrew
thank you very much for the update on
that and again we will simply note that
item
moving on to item nine audit reports
issued to date
to receive a report from dominic
measures from dev nordic partnership
and this is pages 47-106 so
over to you dominic right uh thank you
chair
um again it's a bit like external audit
this report
was due to be considered at the march
committee
um and at that stage there was
i think listed five audit reports that
had been issued
that as you'll see has been extended now
um so that there are 11 audits that have
been reported since the january
committee i am pleased to say that
uh of those a number quite a few were
of high or good standard which left just
two
the harbours and pilotage and the estate
management
um with a an audio opinion of
improvements required
i don't propose to go through them in
any great detail but i will
attempt to answer any questions that
members may have
right thank you very much indeed dominic
um these have been previously circulated
when they were councillor craigie you've
had your hand up and wish to speak
can you hear me now hello
we can hear you um on page 54
it was just a small point um which i
i was going to ask last year but i
thought there must be moving for it
why are we um on the publix works loans
um 814 000. it says
interest rates on this debt are high um
why why can't we just pay it off and
save ourselves a bit of an interest on
that
hey do you want me to respond to that
one
yes please steve um uh yeah yes council
secretary
the interest rates are high the historic
uh loans and
historic rates uh which were fixed at
the time that the borrowings were taken
out
um we have done some exercises to
determine
the um financial viability of redeeming
their loans
early um but there's penalties that have
to be paid
on early redemption and the financial
analysis
meant that it was more cost effective to
continue
as they paid off in their current format
rather than
redeem them early
okay thank you so much thank you
right okay thank you um does anybody
else wish to make further comment
okay well thank you very much for that
presentation dominic and thank you for
the work that your team do
during this difficult time
we just note those reports and move on
to item 10
for the audit manager's opinion and
that's to receive a report from dominic
measured again from devnotic partnership
and these are recommendations and pages
107 to 124 on the agenda
uh thank you chair um just one thing to
point out
i think there was a slight error on the
uh on the papers
in that you'll probably have spotted or
certainly on my copy that
one of our end of year our annual report
has been repeated twice
um it was attached as part of the
previous item when it should
in fact it should be uh considered as
part of item
item 10. in that it's our overall
opinion um based on the work that was uh
undertaken uh during 2019
and 2020. now
this is uh a report again that
is is typical for this time of year
under the public sector internal audit
standards the
the head of audit is required to present
to members a summary of all the work
that internal audit did
um last year so that uh an overall
opinion can be
uh presented to you which can then be
used as part of
the uh included in the annual government
which i believe the draft copy is
following
this report um so just to go through the
report i'm not going to cover it in
in a huge amount of detail just to point
out um
some things the main thing is that we
can provide an overall assurance of a
substantial
assurance um that's on on
page 100 and if i look at it correctly
on
sideways 112 and
the bottom in very small writing you can
see the four levels of assurance that we
give so
you're at um we can't give you full
assurance but we can give you
substantial assurance based on the work
that we
we undertook um just going
on to uh page 113. on the right hand
side there's this
colorful kind of diagram that outlines
the way
um all the different ways that we've
arrived at assessing the level
of assurance that substantial level of
assurance
so we're talking about all the all the
audits that we completed in 1920
um some of the follow-up action taken in
uh
audits from previous years um and and
continues through
um looking at various risks that are
cropping up
uh then we move on to uh page
115 um
time the first the first bit less
um times are changing well
certainly since march times have
completely changed
um obviously this report doesn't really
take into covid kovid only came in
really at the very end of 1912 the audit
1920 year
um so the impact of covert we were very
much
more highlighted in uh this time next
year in our end-of-year report but of
course we'll be reporting to you
as we continue our audit work throughout
2021
we then move on and looking at the
results of old it work
in page 116 of your agenda we can see
that the vast majority of the work
um came out with audit opinions of
either high or good
which i'm very pleased to say um again
there's the definitions of those
assurance levels are presented at the
bottom of
that page
also just at the top of the the
following page page 117
internal audit is just one of a number
of
organizations or bodies that provide you
with a assurance
so there are our external auditors uh
andrew and and his team providing uh
assurance local government ombudsman
north devon counts or on
premature arrangements etc so
just to list it there also on page 116
we talk about
our foreign prevention and detection
that you take part in the
national ford initiative exercise that
occurs every two years and we can report
that there were estimated savings in the
region of 35 000 pounds as a result of
taking part
in that exercise um we then move on to
page 117
page 118 it's talking about our delivery
and uh and what we do there and then on
100 page 120 we talk about our our
performance and i'm pleased to say that
uh
the targets that have been set have been
met
and in some cases have been there's been
improvement
um from previous years which i am i'm
pleased to
present uh we then talk about in
page 121 appendix 3 is
that sets out each of the inter each of
the audit
assignments that we did on the right
hand side is the overall opinion for
that
audit and um provides in a
nice colorful presentation uh the
type of assurance the level of assurance
so dark green is high
the pale green is good and then the
amber is where improvements
are required um and that's all i
i propose really to um to say on that
report
right thank you very much indeed dominic
yeah sorry to disturb you just to let
you know that councillor heppel has now
joined the meeting
oh welcome councillor heckler thank you
to have us have you with us yeah
apologies for uh lateness but uh just
got back
yeah we understand we were advised you
might be late to the meeting
thank you thank you for tuning in all
right
uh councillor craig you'd like to speak
thank you um i don't know if this is the
appropriate point
but uh on the harbours there seemed to
be quite a lot of criticism about what
we're doing with the
the harbour and how we're not making
good use of it
and um not keeping things under repair
is there any improvement from last year
who would like to respond to that
um sorry
steve yeah uh which particular aspect of
the harbor council of creighton was
talking about well
um because this is the the audit of
systems within the harbour
are you talking about that or you're
talking about the general development of
the harbour
as a kind of an attraction or
anything both really because they're
both coming out as
low aren't they only on the scale of
uh they need improvement don't they
yeah so in term in terms of the the
harbor in terms of development obviously
we've got a harbour board
um which um is going to report
to cnr if you like so any um aspects of
improving the harbor as a facility and
somewhere to go to
uh would go through the harbour board
and any recommendations then
considered by cnr for adoption so
um the audit commit audit governance
committee is there
isn't the committee to consider consider
those items
in terms of the harbour board in terms
of controls
i think that was on the previous item
[Music]
yes it was steve um
now the the there was we did pick up on
on a few uh items around the repair and
maintenance
overdue inspections um there was a
missing certificate
um for lifting regulations
um yeah and i think we we pointed out
that there was no proactive maintenance
uh plan in place at the time of the
audit
um i'm not in a position unfortunately
to be able to say what progress has
actually been made
but um i know that the responses be
obtained from management
positive so
i don't know whether officers other
officers can
help fill in on the on the missing gaps
okay thanks dominic um councillor craig
and council hackathon
if i can't if we could put those on the
action list i can take those away
and ask for an update on those
um issues to be reported back to
the committee at this next meeting
yes thank you thank you very much steve
thank you
does anybody else wish to make any
comments any questions
right okay well the internal annual
audit plan confirms that the necessary
controls are in place
for our key systems and the internal
auditors are confident
that the scope of the audit plan and the
resultant testing allowed them to
provide the council with a substantial
assurance for 1920
we have a recommendation which i'd like
to move from the chair and the
recommendation
is the audit and governance committee
are required to consider the assurance
provided alongside that of the senior
management
corporate risk management and external
assurance
including that the external auditor as
part of the governance framework
and satisfy themselves from this
assurance for signing the annual audit
government statement
in september 2020. that's a
recommendation i'd like to move
um would somebody like to second
i'll second it thank you very much
councillor hudson
so a recorded vote has to be taken so
kirsty would you like to do
a recorded vote please
thank you chair councillor craigie or
councillor hackett or councillor heppell
councillor hudson
laws you're muted
very sorry for thank you
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much
so we move on to item 11 which is the
draft annual governance statement
to receive the report of the service
improvement officer
so over to you chris oh sorry um
councillor hudson's
would like to speak uh thank you chair
um i'm sorry i was
trying to find an email because some of
the questions counselor craig ears
raised about the harbour board
were very similar to questions i asked
before the meeting commenced
and it's just to let this committee know
they have been answered
in full um by richard haste
who is the officer who now has
responsibility
and i think you will find that um his
response
answers any concerns that we might have
raised and i'm quite happy to share
these questions and answers
with my fellow committee members
so sorry it's a bit late i was
desperately trying to find
my email uh just to confirm that this
was correct
so it's just a point of information
thank you thank you very much indeed
councils and thank you claire for that
that's fine so if that circulated round
that might inform the committee
and thank you um so
if we move on to item 11 which is the
draft
annual government statement and chris
if you'd like to take the floor please
okay thank you chair
and each year the council's required to
report on the effectiveness of our
governance arrangement
[Music]
something that's signed and published
with our annual accounts and that will
be done in september
this is a chance for members to actually
look at the draft of the govern
statements and comments
before i go into it there's a couple of
things this year um
the first one we do try and make sure
that our statement is
concise and accessible to people so this
year i did actually do a sample of
about a dozen ages from different
councils across devon
and our in our kind of um family
similar councils um the majority of them
had
20 to 30 patients small written texts
are quite difficult to read
so my conclusion was that i i think our
format is
my opinion best in practice i'm kind of
stuck with our format this year
so i think it is concise easy to easy to
access
um secondly although kobe didn't impact
on our government's arrangements this
year
um produced a document in april called
matters to consider as a result of the
current violence pandemic and they asked
that we actually did
including a statement um an initial
statement to the impact of curving 19 on
the council's governance arrangements
so we have done that in this report and
finally before we get on to the report
um we have a governance database that
supports our um
compliance with the government's
principles and on page one to eight
i'll just include a summary of um how we
are doing against those principles
um we never kind of get 100
but i've been looking after our
governance report for seven years this
is about the best i've seen
in terms of overall compliance so we do
move forward all of the time
right chris if i could just um pause you
there for a moment
councillor jones has indicated that he
wishes to speak
if you'd like to make a comment now
councillor jones
yeah thank you jeff um i'm new to this
committee so i'm just going to ask a
very
basic question so on this um
summary that we've just been discussing
i mean as far as i can see it all
looks rather good the only outlier is
obviously e1 which is
uh scored at 80 regarding develop the
entity's capacity
would anyone be able to explain is
actually
meant principle e particularly e1 and
why it's so much lower than
everything else i mean the next lowest
score i can see is
89 well 89 which is the average than 95
so
thank you yeah that's right
the main thing there is um our
management plan is out of date
so he's done quite heavily and that's
actually an action in this year's plan
that'd be done by the end of this year
got that particular principle down
because i must imagine three years old
and i thought that was kind of
significant
otherwise
do you wish to come back on that um
cancer jones
no thank you i'm quite content okay
thank you dave thank you
councillor craig you have your hand up
yeah
thank you um on that page um on the
defining outcomes in term
of sustainable economic social and
environmental benefits
we've scored a hundred percent which
quite surprises me
do we have a a carbon um
emissions report for everything that we
do
um i believe we do for all our main
buildings and everything
um we tend to go through this these
different principles
i'm happy for the next meeting i can go
through that one in detail if you like
at the next meeting
and go through it in full um look at all
the evidence
in september if that would help
i'm just sorry i'm just um
well like councilman jones really trying
to work out how you work out
what this score is um basically sit for
give advice on
you should have these particular things
in place and
i kind of provide evidence that council
has these things to take off the sip the
list
and if we take them all off i kind of
say that's about 100
and then the committee can review that
list and say what about this what about
that
and challenge that
okay so can we see this list of um
fifa so that we know what um
because maybe in terms of economic
social and environmental benefits it
needs a little bit of
changing yeah basically we can go
through that
list for that principle see we could go
through the next committee in full
and i'll show you the evidence we've got
and you can challenge that evidence
that's fine
yeah i i'm sure you've done it
accurately i'm not
no but i just um i feel maybe
a hundred percent in this you know
perhaps a little bit unrealistic but for
you know the amount of work that we've
actually achieved because we haven't
even had
had the renewable committee yet um
and i can't see that we've actually
achieved a great deal in that field
so um just surprises me you know
but if that's the measure you're
obviously recording it against the
measure that you're required to
measure it on so so that's okay i mean
thank you
i'm happy i can go through that detail
in september
that would be quite good okay councillor
jones has indicated you wish to speak so
if you'd like to come back in david
thank you chair
sorry to return to my original question
i just had a follow-up that came to mind
you were saying that the management plan
is out of date
um when was the management plan
due to have been updated would that have
not updated as we
um started a new council and if that was
the case why hasn't it been updated
and why is it only being looked at now
thank you yeah it's actually the asset
management plan and the property team
and this it was due for a uh renewal in
end of 2017
so it's two years out of date and it's
just been a resource issue within that
team
they've been so busy um it came up in
this last year's audits
and we have an action in place to get it
done this year so it was mainly a
resource issue within the team
um and the last um stage manager left
last year
um it's been outstanding basically
thank you thank you thank you
right chris if you'd like to continue
with your report please okay i'll just
talk through the um
the governor's statement page by page so
page
130
this just provides um high level summary
of the governor's principles
page 131 um
it's not the purpose of our governance
framework
page 132 i should summarize this
torridge's governor's firmwork
the different parts and different
responsibilities in there
page 133 looks at the question as of the
officers governance arrangements
page 134 looks at the effectiveness of
their mental
governance arrangements more like
scrutiny committees
page 135 looks at the kind of a summary
of our
external governance arrangements the
internal auditors external auditors
and the other kind of reviews we've had
during the year
and then on page 136 of actually
including an additional page this year
um on active governance of the color
vinus corona virus um
it's kind of really flagging up issues
for 2021
um but fastest to look at this so the
documents current but it's published in
september
i've kind of focused on four main areas
the first one there is that we've been
giving out a lot of grant money to
businesses to support them
um government money around 27 million
pounds been allocated
so we have been asking our internal
auditors to look at that money make sure
there's new
legitimate payments no duplicates and
things
um in terms of the impact on our
services
we've been fortunate managed it well
but basically we've managed to get most
of our services running effectively
throughout the period
but there has been some impact on some
areas like leisure
probably toilets um some existing
projects
but basically the smt have been
reviewing and managing that situation
every single week we've gone through the
last four months
and next one was the financial impact um
i know and the accounts team worked out
the deficits about 2.1 million from
the impact of um covered 19 and
uh section one officer has actually been
reporting
ongoing as the grants come in and
looking back with cnr committee so
that's kind of
being carefully monitored and reported
on and then finally
there's an impact on actual government
service of the council in terms of
meetings
because all public meetings were banned
by the government and
the council set up these virtual
meetings like today so that members
could still make decisions and steer the
council
despite not being able to meet in person
so the main four overs i picked up on
that we need to um
be reporting on next year but also be
aware of this year as well because
they're impacting on our governance
arrangements
and then probably on page 137 um
there's two issues which i've kind of
put in those um
we actually need to improve our
government's film work the first one is
looking by sipfer which is actually
having a review of the council's
arrangements due to covid um so that
will be a review by the senior
management team
during the year uh reporting on impact
on our government's arrangements
so they are fully reviewed the second
one we've already mentioned um
council jones mentioned asset management
plan and again that does impact because
it's out of date so
there's an action there's have that done
by the end of this year so let's find
out to date
um there are the two things i picked out
has been the main kind of governance
risks this year
we're happy to answer any other
questions on the ags
right thank you very much indeed for
your report chris
right would anybody like to make any
comment or observation
any questions
right well that seems to
be content all round so we just
note the report and move on to item
number 12.
the annual government statement review
of government supporting evidence
and that's principle d3 so to receive
the report from the service improvement
officer again
over to you chris on page 138
thank you chair um back in um
january's meeting i did a report on
principal d
and when we got to d 3.4 which is about
um
social value i actually said i had this
down in a red area
so we didn't do this we didn't have a
specific policy in place
without meeting some of the some of you
members i think particularly
the chair and vice chair said hang on a
minute we do loads of these things
we've got a lot of things in place and
we don't think this is read earlier
and i was asked to go away and review my
initial findings
since i had to visit this after the
meeting um
i did come up with 11 examples where we
do indeed consider social value
very highly so i've listed them in in
this report here
um there's two spelling mistakes i
apologize for but basically um
yes members were correct in january and
i was wrong this is actually a green
area not a red one
and we do consider social value heavily
even though we haven't got a policy in
place
for this so
right well thank you very much chris um
thank you very much for doing that
update and um
proven that we do
meet those goals and values anybody wish
to make any comment
right council hudson
thank you uh chris what um
what what is the procedure now we've
actually identified all these things
where we are
uh considering social value do we do
this in a sort of backwards way do we
actually just bundle this
bundle construct carefully a policy
um demonstrating um how social value is
met and where it's met
and just uh brand that as our policy
towards
um the consideration of social valid
value by this authority um
that's a good question probably
if i take that away and discuss it with
our property um yeah property manager
agent redwood i'll have a chat with him
because
he should have been in his area so i
will take that away as an action
yeah as i think i think you've got
you've got it here
it's not a huge piece of work to do um
but
just to actually consider all the areas
that we're doing i
i'm really glad that that's come out i
think that's very positive
so thank you for your work on that
right thank you claire um we'll move on
to item 13 again and have
the presentation of the draft financial
statements for publication as of the
30th of june 2020
to receive a verbal update and financial
statement
19 2019 to 2020 from the interim section
151 officer
so over to david to take us from pages
140.
thank you um just to let members know
that we published our draft set of
accounts on our council's website on the
25th of june
because of the covid 19 lockdown the
statutory deadline had
moved to the 31st of august so we did it
considerably
in advance of the statutory deadline the
previous year's deadline was actually
the end of may
which was the first year of it going to
be used to be the end of june so
we actually did our draft set of
accounts by what was the deadline the
year before
whilst doing it remotely our external
auditors
ready kindly started before we'd
actually finished the asset of accounts
they started on the 22nd of june
um i'll let andrew update you later on
the
work that the external artists have done
but the external audit has been done
remotely
which has led to some additional burden
to the finance team because simply we've
had to give information to them
remotely where perhaps in the past we
would have just handed them
a file for them to look through the
finance team has been mostly
office based during the audit process
however one key officer has
been working exclusively home during the
lockdown
we've had circa four full weeks of
external audits
and i'll say it's mostly complete i'll
let andrew um oh somebody's flipped on
the screen before i finished tom
thank you tom um i'll let andrew give
you a more update but i've actually just
been speaking toshi
who's been our lead external auditor and
i've looked through what we call inflow
which is our
where we gave them information they tick
off various elements of the audit
and most of the things are now the vast
majority of things in our green which
means
they are complete and next slide please
tom
okay the key points but we made a
surplus of 100 151
000 which is after meeting circle one
million pounds with the costs associated
with
the settlement of the legal case i'm
sure members are all aware of
we're proposing to put the surplus to
reserve to meet the funding pressures
arising from kovid 19 in 2021.
some of the reasons we were able to
achieve a surplus we had salary
understand
477 000 various reasons
the implementation of task and finish
within the refuge collection research
went we
dramatically reduced our overtime
we moved to more movement towards
universal credit which meant essentially
this reduced volume of work within the
housing benefits
staff have left the vacancies haven't
been filled and there's efficiencies
from working from one site so we've
saved money in our customer services
department
and with regards to the universal credit
housing benefits and customer service
these savings have been taken in the
budget for 2020-21
and we've had a general level of
vacancies which the council always
experiences
we've somewhat reversed the trend on
homelessness related expenditure we've
reduced it by 108 000 which is a reduced
usage of temporary accommodation however
that understanding needs to be
taken into account that's against a very
high
level of resource that we've allocated
to our homelessness service
we did an insurance retender that saved
us another 81 000
net side please tom
um all the recycling that we do
we are rewarded by our devon county
council but it saves them money as well
and we got increased recycling to make
we generated 188 000
more income there is transport related
savings
primarily enriched rate and the refuge
area in terms of fuel and repairs
and i won't go into too much detail but
we
got additional monies relating to
business rates
um section 31 grants essentially the
government increases the amount of
relief that it awards to
businesses we're compensated by grant
and we take that as income
and we're part of what's called the
devon business rate pool
um all the councils in devon are part of
that
and we um put in less than we thought we
were going to put in and that we
could very hard to judge actually
depending on the performance of the
other members
of the devon pool now the writing in red
there which is a little bit smaller than
i
would hoped uh essentially i'm trying to
explain to members here i don't envy
your task of trying to go through our
final accounts and actually understand
them
because i've whitted away about how
we've got a surplus of 151 000 and then
you'll go and look in our accounts and
you won't see 151
000 anywhere so you won't see it on the
comprehensive
income and expenditure on page 165 and
that's because
that includes some accounting things
that are required by accounting
standards which were reversed out by
statute
and so they don't cost the tax base so
essentially we have a revaluation
of our pension deficit that goes through
our final account
but doesn't go out through our budget
monitoring because it isn't a cost to
the taxpayer
it's ditto with property revaluations
and impairments
and also council tax and business rate
surplus in-year services we don't
realize them to the following year
and accumulated absences so there's
reasons why you'll look at the
comprehensive fingerprint expenditure
statement and you won't see a surplus
151 000 because there's all the items in
there
which are technical of nature and then
if you look at the expenditure funding
analysis on page 191 that's showing that
possession is
zero i.e the expenditures maps by income
so you won't
151 000 surplus there either and that's
because the money were transferred to
reserve
is classed as an expenditure item uh
next slide please tom
uh just highlight some key points on the
balance sheet the value of the council's
property plant and equipment increased
by 1.4 million during the year to 36.5
million
this reflects what the district values
assessment of the council's property
portfolio is
and really in large part because we did
a new additional
office accommodation at cast down came
on stream came live
our pension fund deficit increased by 1
million to 41.1 million
and that's probably a combination of two
factors going different ways one is the
value of stocks and shares
declined as everybody would know because
the stock market took a terrible crash
with colby 19.
so the assets the pension fund declined
however that was largely offset by
decreases to long-term
inflation which reduce the long-term
liabilities of the pensions and so we'd
have to pay out less going forward
on people's pensions the ear march
reserves
and these are reserves which are really
essentially backed by cash their usable
reserves reduced by two million pounds
and that effectively reflected the
utilization reserves to fund capital
expenditure
the money is lost with financial
institutions fell from 10 million to 6
million that's money that we put because
we have cash flow we have spare cash and
we put away for a short period of time
with uk registered
institutions for a fixed one rating and
that declined from ten to six million
however our cash
balances and our current bank account
rolls from 3.4 million into 4.9 million
um we didn't take out any new borrowing
during 2019 and we actually repaid 138
000 of public works long debt during
2019 to enter
next slide please tom
as chris previously alluded to
um the impact of colby 19 was didn't
really impact on the 2019-20
there's a lot down started two-thirds of
the way through march
so its impact on our finances is minimal
we've obviously had to do some cash flow
forecasts
and we've been provided to our external
artists to show that the council has
sufficient cash to maintain this
operation start at least march 2022 uh
with regards to the 2019 20 council i'm
sure
andrew will refer to this later the two
largest areas of estimation are the
valuation of the council's property
holdings
and its pension fund both of which may
be impacted by colvid19
just some members are aware the property
valuation provided by the district value
did not pass any judgment on the impacts
of colbit19 on property valuations
the actress who did the evaluation of
the pension fund included the asset
valuations at the 31st of march
which is slightly unusual normally they
take them a little bit earlier so they
did it later
so if we get more accurately the impact
of the
stock market decline but it was it was
frozen at the 31st of march
um next live i thought that might have
been the last slide
is that the last slide tom that's last
slide david thank you tom
happy to take any questions
does anybody wish to make any commentary
questions
counselor jones david please
thank you chair i was just wondering
with regards to
the overspend regarding legal services
there the
um 1059 obviously multiplied
um what was the original figure in the
budget
for the um expenditure on
legal expenses
we had a budget for legal fees but we
didn't have a budget for the legal
settlement
so that was an unmet that was unbudgeted
expenditure
can i ask what the budget was for legal
fees in that year
i think it was 50 000 pounds
thank you
does anybody wish to make any further
comment
okay the only comment i would like to
make it's been a very clear
narrative report and i'm very grateful
for it um that has appeared in the
document because it explains things
very very well indeed and concisely
council laws you'd like to come in nick
please
yes i mean i'm totally out of my depth
here
how do you sleep at night is what i want
to know
now um can i ask the staffing there was
a
understand of 400 and something that
though are we still short of staff
now in key positions is that what that
is reflecting the fact that
um we budgeted to spend more on starting
so presumably
we're staffed down aren't we
i think that'd be a mixed message
council laws um
so for example some of the underspend on
staffing was because of the movement to
universal credit so that is actually a
movement of work
away from the council to the dwp
so as vacancies arose we didn't backfill
those vacancies within the housing
benefit team
so that was a planned rationalization of
staff
we clearly closed bridge buildings
and losing track of time i think over a
year ago now
um obviously we used to have two
receptions we now have
one reception so we've made some
efficiency savings within the customer
services
team in terms of richard hastie's error
which is refuse
when we introduced the new service there
was an element of begging in
and sorting out the rounds and getting
those efficiencies that come
because everything's new and we probably
had the budgets for staffing a little
bit higher than perhaps we should have
done
until the service bedded in and now that
we've moved on to a task and finish
essentially as soon as the chat's
finished and they've done their round
they can go home
that's massively reduced the amount of
overtime that we've paid out
however there are some issues in terms
of the staffing understanding which
simply reflect difficulties in
recruitment
and there's been some long-standing
vacancies within the council
the actual vacancies as percentage if
you take out the
factors of awareness essentially that
the overall staffing budget is less than
two percent so they're not
excessive but there are certain areas of
key post
the council has traditionally found
difficult to recruit to so
i'd say it's a bit of a mixed message
right
thank thank you very much gotta start
learning somewhere
hmm
well
we note that item and go on to item 14
um the draft audit findings
and to receive a verbal update from
andrew davis of grant thornton
iceland auditors so over to you andrew
again
thank you chair um so as
as david as has already set out we we
started the audit
back on the 22nd of june and
we and again as david said we we're
largely complete on that now
we've made we've made really good we've
made really good progress on that
um at the moment the high level message
is that we give we give two two
conclusions we give a conclusion on the
value for money
and we give an opinion on the financial
statements
at the moment there's no issues that
would
would impact on us giving a clean
opinion in in both
in both of those areas um
having said that i do have to sort of
slightly caveat that with the fact that
work is still ongoing um around sort of
some of the work on value for money and
some of the work on
uh we're waiting for some queries back
from the the value of our property
planting equipment
and we've got to get our assurances
around pension fund
because we write to the pension fund
auditor to get assurances from them so
there's a few areas there that sort of
significant risk areas that we haven't
had
all the information back but so far
looking looking really good um we're
looking to
issue the audit findings report in
mid-august ahead of the audit
governance committee on the 27th of
september
um as as i mentioned earlier obviously
covert 19
as has obviously had an impact and we
issued an updated uh plan addendum
setting out that as a significant risk
what what's pleasing uh is that
actually i don't feel that that's had a
significant
um a significant impact as i as i
thought it would do in terms of
the logistics side of things um
it has presented challenges and
obviously
you know working remotely and trying to
do
uh validate data and things like that
has been has been more challenging and
as david said earlier it's actually
probably increased um the the call
on the council's team in terms of
terms of responding to that to that
additional additional challenge
um but you know the the finance team
have done really well they've put
together a solid set of accounts
we've uh so we're largely complete on
that now
all the working papers have been of a
really good standard
and today we haven't identified any
significant significant issues
for our testing
the audit so the audit from our side was
completed remotely and that was just in
line with the firm's guidance
and the fact that uh restrictions on
public transport and staying in hotels
and things because most of the team
would have come from bristol and it
would involve
sort of staying away so we have to
um deliver the the audit remotely and
we'll continue
to to work remotely on on on other
orders going forward whilst
what's the what's the firm's policy is
to do that although
you know we're conscious of the fact
that things are starting to kind of go
back go back to normal now
so i've i've sort of set out there the
key areas that are
sort of outstanding um and i've got
no significant issues to bring to your
attention
other than again david alluded to this
earlier is that the
the valuer has um has sort of flagged a
uh a potential impact of covid around
material uncertainty on
property valuations which
will um which we will
which we will um refer
to in our audit opinion and that's just
effectively it's an emphasis of matter
saying
the council have put there what the what
the value was said about the potential
uncertainty in this area and we just
cross refer to that to say that you know
when you're looking at these values
you need to consider what the valuer is
saying
um and and that is the same with
with with all councils you know everyone
is in
is in the same boat with that and that's
just something that's been created by
covert 19.
um going concern is another area of work
that
we do a substantial amount of work on
we've done more work in that area this
year in terms of challenging about the
the council's ability to to be a going
concern
through to september 2021
we've concluded that work and uh
concluded that
the um the council is again concerned
yeah so that's a real positive um
i think that's that's all i wanted to
say really
um obviously when we've when we've got
the draft
when we've got the audit findings report
and we present that in september
and we'll obviously go into a lot more
detail around the detailed work we did
against each of the significant risks
and
we'll talk you through that then but i
thought it was really important now
having david's just you know he's just
shown you the
talk through the financial statements
just to give you that early assurance
that
you know we're nearly there and and
today there's been no significant issues
all right thank you andrew does anybody
else wish to make any comments
right the only question i think um
i have in my mind is that um obviously
when one has read things in the local
press
about councils and
their issues that they are encountering
from july onwards
we are in your opinion andrew a going
concern
and we are not in the situation that
other councils regrettably have found
themselves in
uh from what we read in the press going
forwards
and unable to supply some of their
functions
going forwards so you think we're in a
fairly healthy position
i think in terms of going concern in
that next 12 months
then you know the there's no issues
around going concern the
you know the council's got a strong
level of reserves and has got plans in
place to
um to sort of manage manage its cash
flows
so that but obviously
like all districts there is a challenge
over that that medium term
in terms of you know trying to minimize
the impact that kovid has on
has on the reserves so that sort of
the council comes out of this in a
relatively strong
strong position and you know
obviously that that's reflected in our
value for money side of our work
uh again the arrangements from reviewing
that the arrangements
in place are are strong
and so there's no no real concerns
from outside on that yeah so
we're looking for the medium term
financial planning and
you know i'm relieved to hear that smt
are keeping a very constant review on
this and obviously the qbr will
highlight any issues
um we had our triangular pension review
in january this year
and that sort of built a bit of
resilience in with
covid so i can take assurance on that
if anybody else has any comments to make
if not i will i'll propose to note
the audit findings and we can move on
item 15 update of the financial and
contractual procedural rules
and we're receiving a report from the
interim section 151 officer
on page 247 so over to you over to david
yes thank you chair um just as a little
bit of background to members this is a
report that's coming to you today
which actually had a life a little bit
time ago but and covered 19 kind of
stopped its progress we were obliged to
revive look at revising our finance and
contracts here just to tie in with the
revision to the council's constitution
the report on pages two four
seven two three
two five three
was presented at the to a constitutional
working group
and eventually um we looked at the
contract procedure rules
and we went through them and updated
them for sort of minor things
daily bankings updating the descriptions
of the post update for reference to gdpr
requirements etc
and any um statutory things that
government brought in in the last time
the financial season for updates such as
ir35 regulations
regarding agency staff and then
what the report does then it goes
through those changes where there's a
change to officer delegation and seeks
approval for them
so i don't know um chair would you like
me to just go through each individual
proposal or should i just leave it on
the assumption members have read the
report
and can ask any questions therein
shall we take it as read and if any
counsellor would like to make any
comment
or have any observation i'm happy to
hear from
council hodgson claire thank you very
much
um well congratulations again i
i did ask various questions which were
answered pre-meeting
but the one issue that it was suggested
that
um was pertinent to raise here is the
on page 263
um the item value excluding backs
disposals of land and buildings up to 10
000 pounds now i read this and
i was a little concerned that you're
fine
delegate responsibility however
at times a piece of land which may not
have
much in the way of monetary value
might be extremely valuable to the ward
itself
and i think we need to make sure that
this particular policy
actually includes after consultation
with ward members
now it does refer to the requirements of
the council's asset management plan
and community asset transfer policy
which
may encompass this but i think we need
to make specific
reference to consultation with ward
members before
any disposal takes place
i don't know what anybody else thinks
about this
is
to be honest that would be something we
would do ordinarily but
obviously except it's not written down
so um i don't see any particular problem
with including
um that in there thank you
okay um i had councillor
jones with a raised hand if you'd like
to speak now david
thank you no if that's a proposal i'd
like to second that i think that sounds
very sensible
um like we say there are areas which in
monetary terms might not be worth a lot
or might not be
sold off for a lot anyway but have a
deeper meaning so no i i've been
supportive of that
okay right and counselor craigie
would you like to speak naples ruth
thank you um i just wanted to agree with
council hodgson
i think it should be written down that
the ward members must be consulted prior
to sell
selling of any property
i'd like it to be in it actually in
print so it is a policy that
it has to be done
right um would one of the officers just
like to tell me how they would like to
proceed with that can we write that in
or would you like a recommendation to be
voted on
okay you're voting on a number of
recommendations anyway
so that can be um written in you can add
the words
in consultation with uh relevant ward
member
the these um kind of draft
still until they finally approved by
full council
which we would do alongside the rest of
the constitution
constitution changes following the the
working group
meetings of last year and i think the
proposal at the moment is to bring those
to full council
in september right we have a set of
recommendations in five
recommendations a and b
[Music]
and within b we have three other
recommendations
abc can we add that
as an additional recommendation for us
to vote
and would the committee be happy if iso
move
to adopt all those recommendations on
block
do i have a seconder for that proposal
council hudson you wish to speak i know
i
second that thank you very much so we
are
the recommendation is that we adopt
recommendations
a and b and b subsections abc
and the additional recommendation that
was previously
um read out
as they appear on page 253
so if you'd like to take a recorded vote
kirsty
thank you chair councillor craigie or
councillor hackett councillor heppell
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you kirsty
we'll move on to item number 16 waivers
and non-compliance with procedural rules
and we're to receive a report from the
service improvement officer chris
and it's pages 359 to 368.
thank you chris thank you chair um
each year we report to members um on any
massive non-compliance
with the contract and finance procedural
um
and these are called waivers to the
rules
that's about nine years ago now back in
2011
um waived for particular reasons and
there's four kind of categories
one is life or death one is increased
cost loss of income
predicted markets and either is
embarrassment
and as long as one or more of these four
things are
in place there is a routine we can
actually produce a waiver
to the rules um obviously keep a close
eye on the waivers
we monitor them um and
over there they've been going eight
years now over the last three years
we've seen the large number of waivers
um and this year was actually the lowest
of sort of seven levels this last year
um which kind of indicates that
basically we are
minimizing the use of waivers and they
are being used anywhere necessary
so in terms of this year the seven
waivers
two of them were to do with the high
street fund bid which obviously that's
got very tight time scales
and there wasn't actually time to do the
formal tendering process for something
because you would just miss deadlines um
and the other waves are all really kind
of down to
um not being able to get the number of
quotes you want
um it's normally you know we say we want
five quotes we're going to get one back
or two back
so it's kind of been more driven by that
type of thing um
we watch the waivers overall and um
most of them come from the property team
as you'd expect because they do with our
contracts
um if you look on page 363
for some of the waiver process um
we've got kind of a kind of a bus person
to challenge this
so the manager will decide wait for the
rules
they can't follow the rules um we'll
discuss it as the lead member
it then goes through to the governance
team the governor's team will challenge
that look at his financial implications
um if it's
over certain limits it would go to to
members otherwise it goes to either the
head
of the chief executive or the 6151
officer
to be approved uh obviously reporting a
waivers through
this committee each year so you're aware
of the waivers
and then pages um 364 onwards just a
list of last year's waivers
[Applause]
on the basic reason why why they were
requested
um like mainly there were limited
markets not enough tenders returned
other reviews of existing contract
arrangements which it would have
not been sensible to change but any
questions on those waivers
i'm happy to answer
thank you very much chris does anybody
wish to to speak on those any questions
to ask
no right well
we will simply note to the report and
thank you very much indeed for
presenting it chris so we'll now go
on to the next item item 18
item 17 chair i beg your pardon sorry i
was waiting for the
slide to change the housing benefits
subsidy appointments of independent
reporting accountant
to assume that the chair there isn't
actually anything to report on this
other than to say
um grand thornton our external auditors
are still our independent reporting
accountants for the housing benefits
subsidy claim
thank you very much indeed thank you
steve so we'll bypass that one i'm going
to item 18
the external audit fees 2018 19
and 2019-20 to receive a verbal report
from the interim paid service so back to
you steve
okay uh thanks chair um so
members of the the committee have been
on the on the committees for some time
will be aware of uh the
audit fee process so um each year
our external auditors set a as what's
called a scale fee for the
audit work each year
then occasionally there's additional
work
required to meet um
things that may change so changes in the
internal audited standards kind of the
insurance framework and so forth
um so more recently in the in the the
last two years
um there have been um requests
for additional fees for our external
auditors to complete the work they need
to
complete to sign off the um
statement of accounts for 2018
and 19 members of the audit committee
raised some concerns
in respect of the audit fee increase
um and ask that i um following
challenges i've
um obviously put in place with our
external auditors with alex ward
wally who's our audits lead
in terms of those fees there's a set
process that has to be followed if we
disagree with
audits or external audit fees which
results in public sector audit
appointments
national body responsible for external
audit
contracts to first
first of all try and facilitate a
discussion between audited bodies and
external auditors uh to reach resolution
and if not they adjudicate and determine
whether the increased fees are
justifiable or not
in the case of the 2018-19 fees
the additional audit fees psaa
have determined that the increase was
justifiable
and and therefore we've uh paid the
additional some
for 2019 20 obviously that work
um in terms of audit fees and audit work
is just
being concluded um so if i draw
members um attention to back all the way
back to page 42 of the
uh your report um you'll see in there a
schedule
that um andrew
goes to in uh the grand thornton report
of
uh audit fee so you'll see at the top
then the scale original contract fee
uh for 19 20 or 31 792
and then there's some items um adjusting
uh that fee with the the rationale for
the fee variation
on the the right hand side bringing the
rise scale
fee of thirty nine thousand two hundred
ninety
two and i wanna go in i wasn't intending
going into the details
of each of those items because it is
um highlighted there um the additional
work that the external auditors
have have gone through um in order that
they
meet auditing standards um
david hayes uh myself have had
discussions with alex and uh andrew in
relation to fees
and obviously david and andrew boat both
outlined
uh this afternoon with the additional
work uh that's been involved through
a result of coronavirus um in terms of
the the work
that's have been involved so we haven't
reached a conclusion on the 9
8 19 20 audit fees as yet
uh so those discussions are still
ongoing
um but happy to take any members views
on board
uh for those discussions uh should there
be any
thanks chair right thank you steve does
anybody wish to
make any comments or speak on that item
and you recall that we did a very robust
challenge on it at the
meeting last year and also we took it
all the way up to westminster when we
had a conference
and we were not alone in making the
comments
about the fees council hudson you wish
to speak
uh yes thank you that was a perfectly
clear
explanation of what took place
with regard to the fees um perhaps i'm
anticipating and perhaps this isn't the
time or the place
but should we as an audit committee be
looking at
potential costs going forward
because um with regard
nationally all local authorities have
been given
huge amounts of money to dispense very
very quickly
for um in response to covid and the
grant administration
now i would not want to see something
that was undertaken
[Music]
by every local authority working all the
hours under the sun to get these grants
out
to be seen as an opportunity to charge
fees for auditing at the grants
um and i think that would be
uh not in the spirit of how this money
was uh
but spent so i just want to put a marker
in the sand really
to say that i wouldn't want to see an
exorbitant increase to allow for
auditing of these accounts whilst i do
fully understand
fraud and the issues that could
be revealed um
i just wanted to make that statement
because i think it's important that the
audit committee considers that that
potentially is something that we could
be looking at
i i share your views yes steve jay if i
think it could add a little bit um
obviously as council hodgson mentioned
it's it is a national issue
and it's it's not um simply an issue of
additional work um all the
auditing standards have changed the
there's a new national audit office
um code
that's been that's been changed that's
been updated
so kind of independence of our external
orders there's
there's a a lot of changes uh
going through in the audit world i sit
on an advisory board
nationally with public sector audit
appointments
representing all district councils uh on
that forum so
um it is recognized there's a there's a
lot of work
now required following a lot of private
sector
audits and sorry not audit issues but
audited things that come out through the
audit process
in terms of very big companies
and perhaps um
trying to word this correctly um through
their financial statements and collapses
and so forth
and um so there's there's a there that
there are
a lot of changes put in the audit world
and similarly in terms of financial
resilience
value for money um
you know a lot of things need looking
forward rather than looking back so it's
not
simply a case of a statement of accounts
now
the value for money the financial
resilience elements
of the work of the auditors is not
simply looking at the set of figures and
looking at
invoices it's forming a very detailed
uh forward-looking opinion of the work
so
understandably i guess there will be fee
increases and i think nationally we
recognize all that additional work
but is something it is being discussed
and debated
nationally thank you
just throwing a ball in the air have
there been efficiency savings in the way
audits have been done
because now it's being done remotely or
not moving staff around the countryside
and in addition i know that
david's team have done an absolute
first-class job
in finding information scanning it and
getting it back to the auditors
and i think we we owe his team uh ren
peter
all of the team a debt of gratitude for
the work they've put in
during exceedingly different
circumstances and making this audit
a practical proposition to go forward
with
but um as for efficiency savings i don't
know are there any
any comments to make on that or are we
being
too premature in looking at that hi
chair
i am sorry andrew davis here andrew yes
um yeah i mean i i it probably is too
early to see in terms of
um the the costs of
obviously people not staying in hotels
to deliver audits but then there's
obviously
there's an offset where actually what
we're finding is um
i mean we're still quite early in the
local government cycle given the change
the deadline
so what what we haven't seen and what
we've seen through health is that
through our health accounts work is that
actually audits are taking longer
um purely because of that sort of remote
working and
trying to get the information whereas i
think
you know whether i mean me personally my
own personal view is that i
i prefer to do audits on site i think
it's more efficient it's
it's it's quicker and you you get things
get get things done quicker but whether
whether we end up in a hybrid model
going forward i i don't really know but
i think it's probably too early to say
whether there's any
efficiencies at the moment all we're
seeing really is the
um sort of the increase in the amount of
time it's taken to do that
and as steve had said the you know the
the finance reporting council
and this is sort of links into the
additional fees
one of the things they've really sort of
um
increased and raised the bar on is
around where
we're actually trying to sort of
validate
the data that the the councils are
giving us
so rather than just accepting it you
know we're having to sort of make sure
that that's come from the source
it's come from the source data or trying
to triangulate it by getting it from
various sources so we can validate it
and
this is some of the way david's team
have felt that increase some of that has
been created by kobe but some of that
actually comes from the fact that the
frc is
increasingly ramping up the um
the challenge that we have to have to go
into now around the
information provided by the by the
councils
okay thank you thank you for your views
thank you
any further comments for anyone to make
otherwise i will note
our note that item and move on to item
19 which is the audit forward plan which
you'll find on page 369 of the agenda
pack
right
chris would you like to take us through
it um
it's all laid out there oh thank you
chair
um obviously next meeting is the kind of
combination of the audi uh
um with it being signed off so
grant thornton are back with the audit
findings reports
on your audit letter um then we have the
um
accounts being approved along with the
letters of representation and annual
governance statements
that's kind of the important uh meeting
of the year
growing concern as well from the
accounts team um we're kicking off the
meeting with a
report um presentation on the pension
fund from devon county council
looking at how the money is actually
invested and why and how
um devon audit partnership will have a
report on the effectiveness of the audit
committee
one of my usual copyrights register then
we'll have the usual items of the order
reports issued
and i look at the actions agreed and we
put back on the progress anything
outstanding
so it's quite enjoy again next time a
very full agenda
yes right
um
if anybody has any comments to make on
that otherwise
we will move forward and i'll move on to
item 20
which is the exclusion of the public
and i wish to move that the public be
excluded from the remainder of the
meeting because of the likely disclosure
of exempt information by virtue of
paragraph
3 part 1 and paragraph 10 of part 2
of schedule 12a of the local government
act
1972. and i'll call for um
somebody to second that please i'll
second that chair
thank you very much and we will go
to the recorded vote so over to you
kirsty
thank you chair councillor craigie four
councillor hackett four councillor
heppell
four councillor hudson
or councillor jones
four councillor laws four
vote was unanimous chair thank you very
much kirsty thank you
right so
i when i thank the public for attending
and now is the appropriate time for us
to go
into a closed session thank you charles
just remove us from youtube and i'll let
you know when to continue